Oh
first of all kudos to this girl okay
she's willing to admit in front of a
group of strangers in her coworkers oh
by the way I've a midget okay
kudos to her lovely this is not
happening
I'm your host Roy Wood jr.
some say it only lasts 15 minutes some
people are going to tell you it's a
mythical creature that lives at the
bottom of the rainbow some will tell you
not to overdo it I say enjoy while it
lasts
they're the best times of my life was
being a guest on this podcast about last
night Williams everybody
[Applause]
about two years in the in the comedy I
get a headliner gig which is insane
there was a drop out and they needed
someone they got me
it's a casino in Temecula California now
if you don't know where it Temecula is
start doing meth you'll end up in
Temecula okay you just get there
eventually
um so I'm doing the gig there it's the
night after my first show it goes really
well this is a Friday night and then I
get a phone call and and it's some
organizer from a golf tournament saying
hey we're run a celebrity charity golf
tournament that's playing here tomorrow
one of our celebrities dropped out do
you want to play in the golf tournament
now you might be thinking why is he
calling a midget to play in a golf
tournament he was probably thinking that
same thing but I play golf i frickin
play golf and before you make the joke
you not miniature
I play actual dog I'm not there lose the
wind me alone I'm not doing that I play
real golf okay my dad started me playing
golf when I was 2 years old
alright so I'm actually kind of good at
it and but I think the only reason why
my dad started me playing golf is not
because he wanted to spend time with me
because he want to advance my character
or nothing like he just wanted to make
dad jokes he just wanted to make dad
jokes that's it like my dad's not a
dwarf he's tall so he loves making dad
jokes and like so when we go play golf
he make the same one every time his
name's Pete and all his friends would be
like hey Pete you're taking a kid up to
play golf is he any good
and his response would always be he's
okay but he's got a hell of a short game
every time not some of the time every
time to the point where I would be
mouthing the joke along with him just
standing behind him and you think that's
bad but I started to like it all right I
started to like it I started to like the
game and I started like dad jokes to the
point where I would write my own where I
would show up with my dad and be like
hey Pete you're some blaze golf
what's his handicap and I would yell out
dwarfism you asshole
so I played golf
and I had my clubs with me that weekend
so I was like yeah I'll play in the
celebrity golf tournament that sounds
awesome
by the way I'm not a celebrity I don't
think I'm one now I certainly wasn't one
back then but they wanted me a place so
I said all right cool
all right meet us down here tomorrow so
I go down the course the next day I got
my little golf outfit on and I'm not
gonna lie to you a midget in the golf
outfit is adorable okay it's awesome
like I look like the top of a
four-year-old's birthday cake it's
pretty incredible so I walk and I got my
clubs now for the for the celebrities
they all have their names on their carts
and then they have non celebrities
playing with them so they know where to
meet up they mean that their celebrities
cart so I'm looking for my cart and I
don't see my cart I'm looking at my all
right there's Bill Engvall that's cool
there's screech true he was there and
then there was the guy played Carlton on
Fresh Prince Alfonso Ribeiro he was
they're not the best celebrities but I I
can't find my cart I'm looking all over
I cannot find my cart so I go to this
tournament organizer and I say hey
when's Brad Williams I'm a celebrity I
don't have a card but if you ever have
to say I'm a celebrity you're not a
celebrity all right don't go take a
picture I'm no you're not okay so I'm
aware that I'm not a celebrity so I I
can't find my card he goes oh I know
where your card is and he takes me to
this card and there it is right there on
the nametag we man
[Applause]
for those of you who don't know I am NOT
him but that is something that as it
happened to every dwarf their entire
life okay we always get mistaken for
other little people usually it's the
midget of the moment whoever that is so
10 years ago we were all we man from
jackass
sorry and that sucks that sucked
people think you're wee man they run up
they kick in the balls they saw see the
shopping cart it's horrible now it's not
so bad now everyone just thinks I'm
Dinklage from Game of Thrones
okay that's not that bad I don't mind
people think I'm dateless that's cool
like he's funny he's a great actor in
the show he bangs a lot of hookers like
I feel like he's so popular I could just
run to a random woman start humping her
leg be like I always pay my debts
if you watch the show that's hilarious
you don't watch the show you have no
idea where everyone's laughing right now
that's funny to me
so most people if this happened to them
would get really pissed off very angry
me I'm a sick freak comedian and I go
this is gonna be a great story like I
don't freak out I just look I go all
right I'm wee man today now I was gonna
tell my group of non-celebrities the
whole story cuz I didn't want them to be
disappointed all right but then as soon
as they saw me standing in front of the
car
they lit up and they're like oh my god
we're not women yes we got a good
celebrity our friends got to play up the
ShamWow guy that sucks and so like their
to their site there they're beyond
thrilled to be playing with wee man and
I'm like I can't break their hearts I
can't be the guy that's like I'm
actually a comedian you don't know who i
am but maybe i'll be on Comedy Central
one day play I can't do that so I go
alright I'm gonna be wee man and god
dammit I was wee man that day I was what
we're playing I'm telling them stories
about the show this is when jackass was
in its heyday it was in its prime and
they're asking me questions I'm
answering them I don't know the answers
but I'm just like saying stuff they're
like a steve-o crazy I'm like let me
tell you is crazy steve-o story started
there like you guys get a lot of girls
I'm like there's STDs named after Steve
oh by the way I'm friends with steve-o
now and I've told him this story
he loves it we're cool sidenote when I'm
hanging out with steve-o it's impossible
to convince people I'm not we man
they're just like you can't know too so
we start playing and we're having a good
time and these guys were drinking or
we're playing holes and we're donating
money to charity I'm getting them to
donate more often times in these special
tournaments holes will be sponsored by
certain corporations they're trying to
raise more money for whatever charity
you're playing for we pull up to a hole
that's sponsored by Hooters all right
and there's Hooters girls y'all got
wings we're gonna eat we're gonna do
that and one of the Hooters girls now
remember I'm driving up in a cart that
says we man on it right I'm driving up
we see the Hooters girls we're all
excited one of the Hooters girls jumps
up walks towards me with her finger
pointing goes that's not me man and now
everyone's like what are we man
[Music]
and then she goes no no no that's not we
man I we man that's not we man
first of all kudos to this girl okay
she's willing to admit in front of a
group of strangers in her co-workers oh
by the way I a midget okay
kudos to her and when that happens I
immediately like run over to her and I
kind of grab her by the wrist I pull her
aside and I kind of explained the
situation to work no I'm not we men look
alike these holes and they I'm not him
but I'm playing along so they donate to
charity they think they're gonna have a
good time like I'm just to play along
with it and then like I peeled off sixty
bucks and if you're a Hooters waitress
and Temecula that's a lot of
money and I gave her the 60 bucks and
she's like all right cool and then she
goes like oh my mistake
that is we man that is we man guys
that's we've once again kudos to this
woman that not only does the water
sexual life is like to these strangers
now she's saying I'm so much of a whore
I could a midget and forget about
it so problem solved right we're all
back to normal the guys start teeing off
I kind of slink to the back to talk to
this girl like so she's like yeah he
came into my orders we hit it off and
then he said he had a hotel room nearby
so I went to the hotel room and we had
our fun that's awesome so yeah he was
such a nice guy like he took pictures
with all the staff and everything and
he's like and she's like here I'll show
you she pulls out her phone if she pulls
up a picture and she goes yeah and then
my mouth drops up cuz I'm like that's my
other dwarf friend Shawn
how many people she told this story I
don't know but from that day on Oh God I
love golf even more and that's one more
dwarf joke that I can make on the course
I'm Brad Williams thank you guys
[Applause]